okay i wanted to have some fun with some
rumors carter you want to do that with
me
oh gosh rumors are never fun with me
because every single time that i got a
dress
lizzo and cardi b addressed some rumors
leading up to the release of their new
track titled
well
rumors
[Music]
the two went live on youtube on thursday
night and it was everything fans could
have ever dreamed of and more
[Music]
oh yeah this is good asmr i think people
are gonna really love this especially if
you're a fan of asmr like cardi this is
one rumor for sure i watch asmr like at
least two three times in a day that's
the only thing that relaxes me and put
me to sleep no benadryl
no melatonin asmr yeah the grammy winner
said that rumor is true so they did
pretty much the entire live in an asmr
whisper
where's my asmr mic y'all this is the
yeah where is i was an artist i could be
a asmr whispery in this dash person
ready all right
okay let me get my room hi everybody the
up rapper made another confession this
time about one specific must-have item
on her writer all of my candies have to
be read
jolly ranchers starbursts
everything is red
wait you got somebody
somebody takes the skittles
and they take all the other colors out
i never see how they do it but i guess
it's all red
how do those
get the blue ones out like that though
i don't know i think they order it like
that bread makes me happy it reminds me
of violence and lizzo she made a
confession of her own i'm hot
okay
i'm drunk too i'm not gonna lie there
were plenty more confessions that were
very not safe for work you can check out
the video if you want to learn more
oh wait can we like cussing
whatever are we cursing too much i'm
sorry youtube youtube i'm sorry don't
don't block us after the duo wrapped up
their 12-minute live they dropped the
music video for their collab proving
what we already knew
cardi and lizzo are straight-up
goddesses i'm feeling good as
[Music]
and cardi who is expecting her second
child with her hubby rapper offset put
her sweet little baby bump on full
display shout out to cardi junior
uh who made an appearance in the video
party ain't popping no that's the
machine nobody listen they buying them
streams they even posted on blogs
overseas lizzo recently joined zane lowe
on new music daily on apple music one
and opened up about enlisting cardi for
the track she to me
has
always done it right everything that
she's everything that she said every way
that she's reacted because you know why
it's because she was true to herself the
whole time right she never did it to
look cool she never did it to be
accepted or to be like [ __ ] superstar
and she has changed
the game forever for a lot of
us she just follows her heart that's
what i love about her
[Music]
what they do
[Music]